new numbers when it comes to policing
right here in the valley
sustained complaints against metro
police officers dropped
by more than half from 2018 to 2019. the
i-team's david charns has more on what
this means for you
david yeah denise this new data comes
from an internal affairs report that is
just out it shows there were 104
sustained complaints
against metro police officers in 2019
compared to more than double that more
than 200
in 2018. so if you check this out you
see here
in in this chart that's in the report
metro terminated 11 employees in
in 2019 after internal investigations
four though were fired in 2018 but keep
in mind though
that this isn't just police officers
this is for the entire
metro department so we're talking about
5 000 employees
this shows where those uh allegations
are coming from what type so
the most is for interaction with the
public then standards of conduct policy
and then body-worn cameras which is
something we talk a lot about
and then down here tied for fifth with
78 complaints
is the use of four so remember though a
complaint does not mean
that that incident was justified and
then this one here you want to look at
the lighter color this breaks down
where these reports are coming from
across the valley
against police officers so you see metro
southeast command
seeing the most this time around with
the northwest command
seeing the least now the 2019 report
also shows that police are often the
source of complaints police officers
themselves
the source of complaints against their
colleagues i'm david charns 8 news now
brian